so once again we have three equal or I
say we say three identical objects they
all have the same mass but we don't know
what the mass is of each of them but
what we do know is that if you total up
their mass it's the same exact mass as
these nine objects right over here and
each of these nine objects have a mass
of one kilogram so in total you have
nine kilograms on this side and over
here you have three objects they all
have the same mass and we don't know
what it is we're just calling that mass
X and what I want to do here is try to
tackle this a little bit more
symbolically in the last video we said a
little bit why don't we just why don't
we just multiply one third of this and
multiply one third of this and then
we're essentially we're going to keep
things balanced because we're doing one
third of the same mass that this total
is the same as this total that's why the
scale is balanced now let's think about
how we can represent this symbolic see
symbolically so the first thing I want
you to think about is can we set up an
equation so where can we set up an
equation that expresses that we have
these three these three things of mass X
and that in total their mass is equal to
the total mass over here can we express
that as an equation like if you a few
seconds to do it well let's think about
it over here we have three things with
mass X so their total mass we could
write as we could write their total mass
as X plus X plus X and over here we have
nine things with mass of one kilogram I
guess we could write 1 plus 1 plus 1 as
3 plus 1 plus 1 plus 1 plus 1 how many
set 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 and actually this
is a mathematical representation and
we've set it up as an equation this is
algebraic representation it's not the
simplest possible way you can do it but
it is a reasonable way to do it if we
want we can say well if I have an X plus
another X plus another X I have three
X's so I could rewrite this as 3 X 3 X +
3 X will be equal to well if I sum up
all of these ones right over here one
plus one plus one we're doing that we
have nine of them so we get three X is
equal to nine and let make sure I do
that one two three four five six seven
eight
- nine so that's how we would set up and
so the next question is what would we do
what can we do mathematically actually
to either one of these equations but
we'll focus on this one right now what
can we do mathematically in order to
essentially solve for the X in order to
figure out what that mystery mass
actually is and I'll give you another
second or two to think about it
well when we did it the last time we're
just the the scales we said okay we've
got three of these X's here we want to
have just one X here so we can say
whatever this X is if the scale stays
balanced is going to be the same as
whatever we have there there might be a
temptation to subtract two of the x's
maybe from this side but that won't help
us and we can even see it mathematically
over here if we subtract two x's from
both sides on the left hand side you're
going to have three X minus two X and on
the right hand side you're going to have
nine minus two X and you're just going
to be left with three of something minus
two of something is just 1 of something
so you will just have an X there if you
get rid of two of them but on the right
hand side you're going to get nine minus
two x's so the X is still didn't help
you out you still have a mystery mass on
the right hand side so that doesn't help
so instead what we say is and we did
this the last time we said well what if
we took one-third of these things if we
take one-third of these things and take
one-third of these things we should
still get the same mass on both sides
because the original things had the same
mass and the equivalent of doing that
mathematically is to say why don't we
multiply both sides by one-third or
another way to say it is we could divide
both sides by 3 multiplying by 1/3 is
the same thing as dividing by 3 so we're
going to multiply both sides by 1/3 when
you multiply both sides by 1/3 visually
over here if you have three X's you
multiply it by 1/3 you're only going to
have one X left if you have nine of
these 1-kilogram boxes you multiply it
by 1/3 you're only going to have you're
only going to have three left and over
here you can even visually if you divide
by three which is the same thing as
multiplying by 1/3
you're going to you divide by three so
you divide by three you have an X is
equal to a 1 plus one plus one and X is
equal to three or you see here and X is
equal to three over here you do the math
one third times three is one you left
with 1x
so you're left with X is equal to nine
times one-third or you can even view it
as nine divided by three which is equal
to which is equal to which is equal to
three